est-ce qu'on peut combiner
réindustrialisation et lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
c'est même l'un et la condition de
l'autre
car le réchauffement climatique va
nécessiter finalement la réduction du
monde on va produire ce dont on a besoin
sur place et les besoins sont vont se
transformer il y a des choses qu'on va
abandonner on va continuer à produire
pour certaines mais pour d'autres qu'on
va abandonner et donc la réduction
j'allais dire du monde et de la
mondialisation va absolument de père
avec donc c'est la lutte contre
l'échauffement climatique c'est-à-dire
la décarbonation les circuits courts le
lien entre consommation et production
c'est donc la réindustrialisation pour
les produits industriels dont nous
aurons toujours besoin à quantité
technologique élevée faible moyenne
c'est le cas de la transformation des
des aliments et donc dans le cas de la
souveraineté alimentaire donc pour moi
le message de la reconstruction
souveraine d'une industrie et le moyen
de lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique d'ailleurs si vous importez
de moins en moins vous n'aurez plus
besoin de cette flotte de container dont
le plus gros du monde est capable de
transporter en un voyage l'équivalent du
PIB du Togo et pour autant c'est quand
même pas arrivé maintenant parce que on
y est pas encore parce que on a vu
l'explosion du commerce mondial et en
particulier du commerce de la marine
marchande là vous voyez toutes les ce
qu'on appelle en français moderne les
Supply Chain c'est-à-dire
de d'approvisionnement et
d'approvisionnement qui ont été éclatés
dans le monde et vous voyez quand même
un rétrécissement des choses peu à peu
c'est très lent évidemment parce que on
est face 30 ans de de mondialisation en
gros 25 ans 25 ans est-ce que quand vous
voyez ça vous dites pas vous goûtez pas
la saveur secrète de la revanche par
rapport à ceux qui se moquaient de vous
quand vous ayez parlé de la
démondialisation
d'abord je trouve qu'il n'y a pas eu
tant de moquerie que ça il y a eu une
incompréhension
moi je suis très surpris de voir des des
orateurs comme Pascal Lamy qui ont fait
la mondialisation aujourd'hui dire
patron de l'OMC oui patron de l'OMC et
il a été choisi à descendre mon discours
à l'instant et qui aujourd'hui n'a pas
un mot de
de repentir sur les erreurs dans
lesquelles par son par la direction
décisionnelle qui nous a fait prendre
il nous en est
donc moi ce n'est pas une question de de
j'allais dire de revanche c'est juste
que j'ai toujours pensé que c'était le
sens de l'histoire quand j'ai porté
cette marinière qui incarnait le retour
la production française il y a eu des
ricanements et alors finalement j'ai vu
beaucoup de chefs d'entreprise de
syndicalistes de distributeurs embrayés
le pas eux aussi se mettent des rayures
bleu marine sur eux-mêmes ou leurs
produits pour commencer à finalement
faire ce qu'est devenu un mouvement de
société c'est un mouvement de société
aujourd'hui irrésistible
on en parlait tout à l'heure
sur le phénomène de la décroissance la
décroissance pour beaucoup c'est un
idéal est-ce que ça l'est pour vous
j'ai envie de vous dire pour moi il y
aura des secteurs qui vont être très
fortement décroissant il faut cils le
pétrole tout s'est industrie ça a
commencé sur le plan financier sur le
plan physique et puis des secteurs qui
vont exploser le recyclage
l'alimentation locale donc vous n'avez
pas il n'y a pas d'idéologie ni de la
croissance ni de la décroissance il y
aura les deux et comme d'ailleurs dans
toutes les révolutions vous avez un
monde qui meurt un nouveau monde qui
n'est celui qui va naître va être
évidemment fait de circuit court de
produits fabriqués
sur place d'ailleurs c'est un peu la fin
du marketing je parlais de ça je trouve
que c'est très intéressant le marketing
c'est les marques et derrière les
marques on ne sait pas ce qu'il y a et à
la place des marques les consommateurs
du consommateur aussi mais le
consommateur impose les origines donc on
entre dans le siècle des origines je
veux savoir où mon produit est fait
comment il est fait par qui comment les
gens sont payés comment ils travaillent
très graphiste tout ça je pense que
c'est un progrès parce que le
consommateur devient un peu
entre dans la dans le mental du
producteur donc il s'approprie les
contraintes et les désirs du producteur
et l'inverse est aussi vrai donc je
trouve c'est très conciliation du
consommateur et du producteur c'est très
bon pour la reconstruction
reconstruction pardon de l'appareil
productif sur place et nous en avons
tellement besoin alors on le sait vous
savez depuis de nombreuses années une
nouvelle vie de nouveaux combats en
particulier en plus de la
réindustrialisation qui a toujours été
votre combat surtout quand vous avez été
ministre il y a notamment aussi la
souveraineté est-ce que Bercy vous avez
dirigé en son temps a répondu à votre
interpellation quant au rachat de ses go
on précise ses goûts c'est une
entreprise qui fabrique des robinets
pour des centrales nucléaires donc
entreprise stratégique et les bâtiments
militaires et des bâtiments militaires
et qui pourraient être achetés par les
Américains et vous avez tiré la sonnette
d'alarme par rapport à ça est-ce que
Bercy vous a répondu à votre à votre
lettre vous noterez que je n'ai pas
seulement tir la semaine d'alarme nous
avons fait une proposition de rachat que
nous sommes venus avec une solution
donc déjà ça dépend un peu tout le monde
donc moi j'étais très bien reçu par le
gouvernement qui évidemment semble avoir
pris des dispositions pour faire en
sorte que ce goût ne sorte pas du giron
français je m'en réjouis est-ce que ma
proposition sera suivie des faits je
laisse le soin au gouvernement de le
dire ça n'a pas d'importance l'essentiel
c'est que ça reste en France donc pour
moi c'était
utile qu'on soit présent et candidat à
ce rachat et et je j'attends la décision
officielle mais je crois savoir que pour
moi les positive donc ça veut dire que
il faut rien laisser passer être présent
sur le front de la reconstruction de
l'industrie la protection de nos pépites
de nos de nos entreprises à haute teneur
technologique celle-ci fait partie de la
base industrielle technologique de la
défense alors il y a il y a un discours
peut-être qu'il est peut-être pas en
tout cas très clair pour le pour le
grand public mais en tout cas il y a un
discours qui revient sur la souveraineté
on entend de plus en plus même d'élite
économiques peut-être pas parce qu'il y
a de l'ami mais quand même de l'été
économique qu'on entendait pas avant
notamment autour du Medef autour même
des grandes écoles reparler de
souveraineté on entend le gouvernement
en parler est-ce que ce sont des
discours ou bien est-ce que vous sentez
qu'il y a une inflexion de la part de
ses élites et deux et du gouvernement
sur ces questions là
il y a beaucoup de d'affichage mais
justement est-ce que l'affichage je
regarde quand même les 10 dernières
années
regardez ce qu'on a perdu
Alstom technique Alcatel
Lafarge
Silor
je parle pas des entreprises de taille
intermédiaire ou inférieures qui est un
carnage bon donc si vous voulez on peut
faire tous les affichages en fait le
vrai sujet c'est qu'il va falloir
maintenant qu'on remonte tous en France
des boîtes perdues toutes les boîtes
qu'on a c'est possible
que tous les pays qui se sont
industrialisés dernièrement c'est ce
qu'ils ont fait ils l'ont fait pourquoi
on serait pas capable de le faire nous
avons les ressources scientifiques
intellectuelles technologique et humaine
nous avons les moyens financiers il y a
un plan de relance de 50 milliards qui
est sur la table
et je vois comment ça fonctionne
franchement si on l'activait encore plus
fortement et d'une façon moins
bureaucratique on pourra avoir des
résultats exceptionnels et puis surtout
on a un entrepreneuriat il y a Olivier
duanzi c'est un homme que c'est pas
qu'un ami c'est quelqu'un avec qui je
partage les convictions sur la reine du
travail il dit une chose très simple il
dit faut partir des entreprises
existantes dans tous les territoires et
que dans ces entreprises on crée les
nouvelles entreprises donc ça veut dire
que il faut financer des nouvelles
entreprises à l'intérieur des PME
existantes des et existants et bien il
faut changer toutes les règles
d'attribution
de financement public et privé il faut
réinventer
il faut se mettre en état de
mobilisation nationale
et tout ce que l'État qui est quand même
qui a une dette abyssale a déjà dépensé
avec les taux d'intérêt qui monte dans
les banques est-ce que c'est encore
possible je vais vous dire une chose
nous n'avons pas à craindre quand il
s'agit d'investissement productif
l'endettement
ça je pense que c'est même nécessaire de
s'endetter parce que il y a des recettes
futures encore le faire on les a on a
l'argent du plan de relance européen il
y a je vous rappelle que on a reçu je
crois
30-37 milliards et que on va devoir
rembourser le double donc ça c'est les
règles européennes mais au moins
utilisons cet argent il est là vous
dénoncez un phénomène j'aimerais bien
que vous nous en donniez la traduction
c'est l'itarisation de nos entreprises
ça veut dire international trafic
regulation arms c'est une c'est une
liste qui établie de façon inattirle
vers l'administration américaine et qui
déclare que tel produit
étant une composante sous contrôle
américain
vous achetez par exemple les catapultes
sur les plateaux de porte-avions de
décollage de nos avions de chasse et
bien cette catapulte si elle est Itard
si vous voulez la vendre sur un autre
bâtiment que vous vendez à l'export vous
français parce que vous l'avez acheté
aux Américains vous êtes obligé d'en
passer par l'autorisation
d'administration américaine c'est comme
ça que
il nous a été interdit de vendre des
rafales à l’égypte parce que il y avait
des composants dans le Rafale que nous
produisons en France sous signature
française par une très grande entreprise
française d'assaut il y avait un
contrôle
oui c'est vrai j'avais oublié j'aurais
dû m'en souvenir c'est une évidence mais
surtout ils importaient des composants
américains sous la liste cita il y a
22.000 composants sur la liste itea dont
des vernis des peintures donc en fait
pour éviter ça et ben c'est très simple
il faut rapatrier les capacités de
production il faut produire nous-mêmes
nos vernis nos peintures nos composants
donc catapultes et se mettre en Europe à
le faire parce qu'on pourra pas le faire
tout seul nous français surtout les
éléments
j'allais dire de défense c'est
exclusivement de la défense Arnaud
Montebourg les internautes du Figaro
réagissent en ce moment à ce que vous
dites et Monsieur avec beaucoup
d'intérêt Chardon Bleu nous dit mais il
faut des fonds de pension français pour
pouvoir financer nos entreprises votre
point de vue sur ça mais on les a les
fonds de pension
c'est les 3000 milliards
épargnés par les Français je rappelle
que la France a une épargne une plus
importante du monde par habitant et ses
fonds de pension sont c'est l'assurance
vie défiscalisée
qui n'est pas utilisé à des fins il
faudrait des mécanismes incitatifs pour
les gens à la défiscalisation il faut
qu'il ne contrepartie donc moi je suis
désolé je pense que 10% des encours
devrait s'investir dans l'économie
productive et comment vous vous faites
ça bah vous dites au collecteur
assurances vie enfin je sais pas c'est à
peu près 50 milliards par an de collecte
au minimum regardez vous allez vous
allez investir 10% 5 milliards dans dans
l'économie réelle et je vais vous dire
personne en Moura parce que l'économie
française elle est formidable il y a des
perspectives beaucoup plus intéressantes
que d'acheter des obligations à
rendement négatif à Singapour ou en
Allemagne dans l'actualité armement de
vous il y a eu l'audition qui est très
marquée il y a vos auditions au
Parlement il y a une autre ordition qui
a fait beaucoup de bruit c'est
l'audition de François Fillon il y a 48
enfin ces dernières heures est-ce que
vous seriez prêt à vendre des rillettes
ou du miel sur la plage rouge
écoutez j'ai compris que l'ancien
Premier ministre disait moi je suis
désolé je fais ce que je veux parce que
je n'ai pas de de je n'ai plus de mandat
je n'en brique pas votre point de vue
sur ça
je
crois qu'il a démissionné d'un conseil
d'administration
d'une entreprise énergétique russe le
premier plan montrant que finalement
lui-même a nuancé son propre propos bien
sûr quand on a été comme moi un ministre
de l'Économie on ne fait on fait un peu
attention avec qui on fait du commerce
c'est vrai
ceci dit si lui considère que parce que
c'est son opinion que la Russie est un
partenaire qui malgré son attitude dans
l'affaire ukrainienne justifie qu'il
poursuivent son activité c'est sa
liberté formellement voilà politiquement
votre point de vue mon point de vue
c'est qu'il y a quand même un tout petit
problème
dans le comportement russe sur l'affaire
ukrainienne violation des frontières
je rappelle que le droit à tout peuple
de disposer de lui-même est une valeur
fondamentale qui appartient à la Charte
de l'ONU elle a été légèrement malmenée
si vous me passez cette féminisme très
désagréable très bon de rien
je voudrais vous faire des réagir
justement une déclaration de l'ancien
Premier ministre au cours de cette
audition et qui a mis en cause un pays
qui effectivement n'est pas la Russie ce
que j'ai rencontré dans ma vie politique
et en particulier lorsque j'étais au
gouvernement des ingérences étrangères
oui j'en ai rencontré
la plupart du temps elle venait d'un
pays ami et allié qui s'appelle les
États-Unis
je porte pas de jugement je dis
votre commission travaille sur les
ingérences étrangères je vous dis que
par exemple j'ai été écouté avec le
président Sarkozy pendant cinq ans par
la NSA
on l'assume lorsque
des documents des services secrets
américains ont futé et tout le monde
s'est fixé sur le fait que le NSA
écoutait Madame Merkel enfin il a écouté
aussi l'ensemble des membres du
gouvernement français sans doute des
autres pays européens vous avez été
d'ailleurs victimes d'écoute de la NSA
vous personnellement d'après les la
documentation publiée par Monsieur
Snowden qui a révélé que 75 millions de
conversations ou de mails avaient été
capturées indument illégalement par la
NSA au détriment des autorités des
gouvernements des entreprises françaises
je ne peux que donner raison à Monsieur
Fillon
la plupart des ingérences venaient des
États-Unis par le droit
extra-territorial
par la l'utilisation du droit de lutte
contre la corruption américain
il y a eu et l'usage du dollar menait de
domination la conjugaison de ces
éléments là on fait que les États-Unis
d'Amérique utilise leurs droits contre
les Européens et de façon systématique
c'est ce n'est pas que l'affaire de
litarisation de notre industrie de
défense c'est les 9 milliards infligés à
la BNP sur des amendes
pour non respect des règles américaines
mais
pas sur le territoire américain c'est
l'interdiction pour les Français de
continuer alors que nous avons signé un
traité de de
réconciliation sur la question nucléaire
avec l'Iran
l'obligation de faire nos bagages en
Iran pour
notre industrie notamment au Tommy je
rappelle que nous vendions 300 à 400 000
véhicules par an en Iran et que nous
avons été obligés sur des sanctions
unilatérale américaine rétablie par
Trump de faire nos valises tout ça pour
découvrir générale Motors continua à
vendre en sous-main des véhicules aux
Iraniens donc il y a là des mécanismes
de concurrence déloyale entre lesquels
il faut lutter et se réarmer oui mais
est-ce que justement le problème n'est
pas européen et notamment par rapport
un autre dossier qui est l'inflation
réduction actes qui a été justement un
soutien américain à sa propre
industrialisation est-ce que là la
solution n'est pas européenne est-ce que
et d'ailleurs est-ce que la réponse de
Bruxelles par rapport à
vous insatisfait je sais pas écoutez
l'IRA a eu pour conséquence de mettre
fin à 60 % des projets de gigafactory de
batterie en Europe puisque il y a un
rapatrièmement massif de tous les
investissements qui étaient partis
s'investir sur notre continent c'est bon
c'est une bonne chose une mauvaise chose
de votre point de vue c'est s'appelle
une politique agressive de subventions
et de rapatriement des investissements
qui étaient programmés sur l'Europe donc
c'est une agression économique
quand vous regardez ça c'est le
réindustrialisateur ou le souverainiste
qui l'emporte moi je suis j'appartiens à
la catégorie de ceux qui défendent la
souveraineté de notre pays donc qui est
je le et d'ailleurs la souveraineté elle
appartient à donc il y a des giga
Factory américaine quitte notre pays
c'est pas grave oui mais ce que je
regrette c'est que l'Union européenne
n'est pas été capable d'imposer des
sanctions car de faire l'inverse aux
États-Unis et d'imposer la réciprocité
nous à chaque fois nous sommes victimes
de politique unilatérale américaine et
nous ne sommes pas capables d'imposer la
réciproque nous avons le même problème
que la Chine et d'ailleurs dans cette
situation géopolitique nous sommes dans
la tenaille entre les deux empires Chine
et Amérique l'Europe qui est un nain
politique est en situation de grave
difficulté économique et l'irah il y a
eu les sanctions Trump
lira et la deuxième symptôme la deuxième
illustration deuxième choc mais là nous
sommes en situation de déclin
extrêmement rapide sur le plan
économique si nous ne sommes pas
capables d'imposer aux Américains une
riposte Arnaud monte elle ne peut
d'ailleurs venir que de l'Europe le
temps le temps file et on pourrait
continuer à en parler des heures vous
reviendrez sans doute vous reviendrez
peut-être dans votre col vous dénonçait
la flambée des prix des énergies c'est
ma dernière question au premier
trimestre le mégawater en France était à
315 euros
alors qu'il était à 180 euros en Italie
164 euros en Allemagne et pourtant le
coût de la production de l'électricité
le plus bas du continent à 50 euros mais
le mégawater alors question où passe
l'argent
notre modèle nucléaire devrait nous
offrir l'énergie la moins chère d'Europe
non vous dites tout à fait la vérité je
me mets et je passe ma vie dans les dans
les petites entreprises et PME vous avez
des factures qui ont augmenté parfois
par 10 20 quand c'est pas 30 donc vous
avez les entreprises qui sont
étranglées et qui vont
se mettre au tribunal de commerce et
certainement déposer le bilan alors
quand on dit ça au gouvernement ils
disent on s'en occupe mais il n'y a il
ne se passe rien sur le terrain c'est à
dire que les montants de l'électricité
ont explosé quand le patron de Michelin
au mois de novembre dit écoutez ma
facture électrique pour toutes les
usines Michelin de France et passer 250
millions à un milliard 250
c'est pas beaucoup par rapport à la TPE
parce que la TPE j'ai un exemple d'une
entreprise je crois dans le Morbihan qui
me téléphone comme si j'étais le
ministre je ne suis pas je ne suis plus
je ne serai plus la question c'est il me
disent vous comprenez on avait 2000
euros par mois et maintenant je reçois
36000 euros qu'est-ce que vous
préconisez l'ancien ministre préconise
je préconise une décision politique du
Parlement de plafonnement du montant
du prix de l'énergie et par voie de
conséquence la déconnexion de du système
de production d'électricité française du
système de formation des prix européens
comme l'ont réussi l'Espagne et le
Portugal n'est pas un Portugal ce sont
mis à l'abri par des mécanismes
souverainistes de très bonnes Alois
merci beaucoup Arnaud Montebourg
l'engagement c'est votre livre qui vient
d'être édité chez en poche chez pluriel
et bien étendu vous y développez un
certain nombre d'idées que vous avez
déjà abordé au cours de cette émission
merci beaucoup
[Musique]